let's answer some audience questions
first one is from Kim Kim says what's
the most outdated or obsolete device or
technology you still use I don't know if
this really counts but the other day I
got one of these new Polaroid style
cameras it's not really outdated in the
sense that it's not an old camera but
it's like a new fuji Polaroid where it's
just kind of a novelty to take a picture
and it prints out uh I mean I guess it's
kind of outdated the other one that I
was thinking of was I do have some
cookbooks which seems kind of crazy
because now every recipe for anything
you could want is on the internet but I
have some cookbooks and I still use them
and they're really good i've got the
Jerusalem cookbook soup for Syria I
don't know i mean our cookbooks
considered obsolete at this point maybe
not probably not it just seems like all
this technology has its use in its
heyday and then for about 10 years it
goes away and gets replaced by something
else and then after that the hipsters
come around in a retro yet i mean the
resurgence of the new Polaroid style
camera clearly is a hipster thing right
i mean i went to a wedding and the whole
thing was that they had these cameras
all over and you could take pictures of
yourself or whoever and then put pin
them up somewhere for the bride and
groom and blah blah blah it seems like
it's sort of that something led by the
hipster moot movement which I'm totally
fine with I have to say probably in a
way I mean record players you know vinyl
is much better sound quality than that
what we have now yeah your ex absolutely
right which vinyl has had a recurrence
also i know people who are super into
collecting pieces of vinyl now as they
describe them and i mean great it's cool
I mean I i I'd it takes up a lot of
space and I know you get the art and you
get though the notes and all this type
of stuff and it's cool uh it's not
necessarily my thing but I do think that
it's cool do you have any vinyl I do not
have any of my own though okay yeah I
don't I don't either and I I'm actually
wondering my grandparents on my mom's
side had a record player which I always
thought would be kind of cool to have uh
some day and they've both since passed
away and I don't know who has it now I
assume it's still in Argentina but i
hope i can find it because it was like a
really nice old one I don't know from
what year but really really nice
record player and that'd be that'd be
cool to mess around with trying to think
if there's anything else i mean i still
have my laptop is still windows 7
professional and uh it's like an actual
laptop I don't have one of the
Chromebooks are the ones where you flip
the screen and it can become a tablet I
just have like a regular laptop with a
15 and a half inch screen it's just what
I like I don't I don't think that's
outdated I mean they still sell them
today although I know now the tablets
with the kids these days are super
popular and plus you could easily just
upgrade the software if you wanted to
that's true that's a very good point
yeah uh all right that's all really i
can think of i know a lot of people tell
me they still used like a paper address
address books and agendas like calendars
not me but i know many people who still
use those and that's uh that's something
i have a feeling that will come back
also